guys how we doing welcome to the channel
this is courtney with good works
tractors today we're going to talk about
the top 10 snow removal mistakes for
tractor owners
it's that time of year the snow pushers
are flying off the shelves just as quick
as we get them in
snow hasn't fallen yet unusually here in
michigan we are in nearly mid-december
i'm going to call it mid-december why
not
but the snow rest assured will be on its
way so pay attention we won't keep you
long
these could save you some time they can
save you some money they can save you a
heck of a lot of frustration
after you're done watching this video
consider giving me a thumbs up a thumbs
down and also hit that subscribe button
that would really help me out
if you see something you like here read
through that description right
underneath the video
there'll be a lot of links down there
where you can buy cool stuff for your
tractor
if you've been wondering what these big
old hunks of steel are right here these
are called snow pushers these go right
on the end of your loader in place of
your bucket very easy to take on and off
there's no other hydraulics required
there's no electric required you just
simply put it on and away you go
the reason these things are so popular
is for the fact that they are good for
small
snowfalls deep snowfalls the light
fluffy stuff the heavy wet stuff and
everything in between i've done all
sorts of videos on these
hla snow pushers in particular and why
they kind of stand above and beyond all
the others that are on the market
so check those videos out we can get
these in all sorts of different colors
and sizes and combinations to fit your
machine whether it's a john deere quick
attach
a skid steer quick attach or even a
custom mount so visit
goodworkstractors.com to get more
information and to place your order
damage to your plowing surface can be a
real bummer and a
very expensive repair i just had my
parking lot out here
resurfaced just earlier this year it
looks fantastic and i want to keep it
that way i get requests all the time
i just got new concrete i just had my
driveway redone we've had gravel for
years we finally got asphalt
what we're staring at right here are
going to be a couple of good options
that are going to protect your driveway
you have uhmw poly for the easy way to
talk about it
or rubber right here either one of these
materials here are going to be very
protective of a paved or concrete
surface
they're going to plow very well also
they're going to be very quiet and very
durable as well
these kinds of materials can generally
be flipped over so you can get double
the usable life out of them also
i've done comparisons on edges including
the poly the rubber and even the steel
ledge so you can see the pros and cons
of each
check out that video if you haven't done
so already if i was going to sum up
anything about this poly material right
here the easy way to say is that it
protects like rubber but it cuts like
steel so if you have that brand new
driveway that brand new surface and you
want to keep it looking good for years
to come
avoid steel at all costs that is a quick
way to cause damage to your drive get
yourself
either this uhmw or the rubber
now i don't know if this one bothers
anybody else out there but it sure
drives me nuts and i do it every year
at least in the beginning of the year
and then what do i do i find myself out
there with a shovel in hand just
picking away at it until it's all gone
now what am i talking about
you drive over the snow before you
remove it before you clear it out before
you plow it out it just drives me nuts
because you'll have a perfectly clean
driveway perfectly clean parking lot
except for
that two track where you drove in or out
whatever it might be so if your pusher
or plow has a steel edge on it there's
going to be a pretty good chance that
you can get rid of
most of that packed snow that you've
driven over already even the uhmw
or that poly is going to do a pretty
darn good job of getting rid of that
however packed snow is just a very tough
job for rubber
so if you have a rubber edge on your
plow or pusher that is specifically
designed to protect the surface that
you're plowing
well guess what it's probably not going
to do a very good job at cutting through
that packed snow
so the best thing you can do in that
kind of scenario is get to plowing it
before you drive over it
a very painful lesson that you can learn
is on a plow that can be used both in
the summertime and the winter time
right here we have a john deere a quick
attach plow for the front of either
it could be a garden tractor it could be
a 10 25 hour it doesn't matter they go
on
on all those kinds of machines right
there but pay close attention to this
pin that goes right through here
generally in the summertime because of
the weight of the dirt that you're
pushing you want to lock this pin
otherwise you're going to find these
trip springs constantly in that release
position there
however when you get to winter time and
you're dealing with hidden obstacles say
it's a curb or
landscape edging or a rock or whatever
it is just off the driveway
if you don't have this pen released here
you could find yourself coming to a
sudden jarring stop and you'll see posts
online on forums of folks that
have either had really significantly
damaged equipment or even hurt
themselves
jamming breaking a wrist ribs lots of
issues that come up lots of painful
injuries that come up
to the tractors and to yourself so it's
very simple it's just this little pin
right here make sure you pull that out
get that in the release position right
up there and then
you'll you'll notice here i can actually
pull that all the way back that's going
to be the trip
action there so if you hit an edge in
the winter time on a hidden obstacle
whatever it is it's going to give it's
just going to rock forward and then try
to
slip over it and come back into position
versus if it's locked
up front it's just going to come to a
jarring stop and hurt everything else
that's behind it
now certain pieces of snow removal
equipment are going to require extra
parts just to keep on hand they're
usable parts they're
sacrificial parts something like a snow
blower right here is going to have
shear bolts or shear pins you might hear
them called similar to what a brush hog
or some other pto driven piece of
equipment would have on the back of your
tractor
you're going to have a couple on on this
type of snow blower right here one on
either end
it's important to know that you have
those on hand ahead of time
now some folks will go their entire life
without ever having to replace the shear
bolt
others are going to have to replace them
on a constant basis
but i want to show you a hidden spot on
these john deere snow blowers that might
already have a handful of shear bolts
spare shear bolts for you you didn't
even know about so take a look right
here along the edge of the snow blower
on the back side near the chute
you may even just have a handful of
holes right here without any shear bolts
in them
wondering what those holes are for well
that's exactly what they're intended for
so stock these up if you happen to shear
one or two of them off make sure you go
to the store right away and replace them
that way you always have a full stock if
you need it
one of the most frustrating signs of
damage that you can have is damage to
your yard
damage to your landscaping damage to
your curbs get yourself
some stake markers okay these things are
what a couple bucks a piece something
like that at least get yourself a
handful of them so you know
after there's 12 inches of snow on the
ground where that line is because i
swear
i tell myself i can tell where the
driveway ends and the yard starts you
know what the few times i've done that i
normally
clip at least a little bit of my turf
off looks like crap in the spring so
avoid that problem now
get out there get yourself some stakes
even a handful of them okay you don't
spend a hundred dollars if you don't
want to
just get a handful so you kind of had
that line up and down and you don't have
to push the limits right you don't have
to go
and get every single micro inch of your
driveway cleared
play it safe give yourself an inch or so
of space there you'll have nothing to
worry about then
one of the worst things you can do is
when you get that first good snow of the
year
is push that snow right off the drive or
the parking lot right to the edge and
then leave it sitting there okay
you got to have a plan for not just the
first snowfall of the year but for the
entire season because oftentimes
you get that first snow the first couple
snows it kind of warms up a little bit
then freezes up
you'll never be able to move that pile
of snow that you have right along the
edge of your
plowing area so push it deep push it
somewhere way back
way further than you think you're going
to need to do to give yourself room to
pile it up to stack it up
as snow continues to accumulate because
sometimes it all melts away halfway
through the winter
other times it just keeps on coming you
run out of room to put it
so plan ahead get that plan in place
every year i feel like out of my shop in
particular i got to figure out a
different game plan of what to do with
the snow
this year there's absolutely nowhere to
put the snow down back behind the shop
we got to bring it all up front and push
it somewhere around up here we're going
to have to get a little bit creative
this year
one of the big mistakes that i try to
kind of guide folks to especially new
tractor owners is going to be avoiding
the lack of traction there are several
ways you can go about improving your
traction let's talk about those now most
often folks want to put as big of a
piece of snow removal equipment on their
machine as possible
it's not so much that it's a big piece
of equipment that's the problem it's
really
that contact surface with the ground
where the problem lies the type of tire
that you have on your machine is going
to make a huge difference the amount of
traction
therefore the amount of snow that you
can push i changed up my tires to this
tread pattern right here specifically
for snow removal purposes
last year on a 4066r i had the r4 the
industrial style of tread pattern
it did terrible it just did awful okay
and i'm not alone in that i've done
videos all about different tire tread
patterns this tread pattern right here
is just going to be designed a lot
better for snow for mud that kind of
application there but
i'm really looking forward to using it
this year so the other main component of
traction
is going to be weight there are several
ways you can accomplish getting that
additional weight that you need
one can be through the use of a ballast
box on your three-point hitch you can
load this puppy up get about 800 pounds
or so a ballast weight
even in my tires right here i've got
about 1200 pounds of liquid ballast
just hiding right in plain sight you can
also add on wheel weights if you want to
as well
but if your machine is just too light
and you're just sitting there spinning
on top of the surface with a big load of
snow in front
it's not going to do you any good so get
enough weight to plant you and help push
you along
and of course in extreme situations you
may even need to add on tire chains or
tire studs
another big snow removal mistake for us
tractor owners is our machine won't
start
isn't that fun it happens at the most
opportune time no it never does
what are those things you can do to
prevent that from happening to you
there's several reasons in the winter
time when it's really cold outside while
your tractor might not start your fuel
system is critical and diesel will
freeze or gel okay technically it's
gelling how do you avoid that from
happening well typically you're going to
want to add something like a
anti-gel treatment all right what this
is going to do
is lower the temperature that it will
freeze at so it's going to lower that
freeze point meaning that you're going
to be able to use it
in colder temperatures before having an
issue this is something where you can
basically buy a can of this it'll last
you all winter long
you can see the mixing ratios on there
you're really not putting a whole lot in
there
so the guys over at lube shuttle parent
company air tech right here sent over
this frost line
minus 40. this is a another german
engineered product right here so i'm
going to be trying this out this year
i'm going to be adding it into my
tractors i'm going to have a couple
machines sitting outside all winter long
i'm looking forward to that
you'll see though it says you can lower
the gelling temperature 18
25 30 degrees just based on these mixing
ratios right here so basically the more
of this product that you put into your
diesel system
the lower the temperature that's outside
you'll be able to operate in
the good thing about this product is you
get five percent off with code gwt order
manufacture direct at the link below
now depending on if you're storing your
tractor indoors or outdoors in a heated
or unheated environment
you may need to get something like this
right here an engine block heater you're
just going to see a plug like this
on the side of your engine compartment
right here maybe even for the
transmission as well
just plug it in give yourself a half
hour an hour before you're going to go
out there and plow you'll be all set
these are something that can typically
be added on by the dealer for maybe a
few hundred bucks
another common problem as soon as the
temperatures start to drop are going to
be with batteries alright so as soon as
it gets
really cold outside you could definitely
have an issue with your battery
one way to prevent that of course
replace the battery or
something else you could do is put on a
battery tender or a trickle charger to
make sure especially if you're using it
infrequently
that you're good to go you don't have
any issues when it's time to push that
snow
isn't that a beautiful sound now if you
want to hear that sound all winter long
make sure you use your glow plugs that's
something that's pretty much standard on
all modern day tractors
so don't just go cranking your tractor
on that's just asking for problems or
asking for it to not start and the
frustration to kick in
it's 20 minutes after five and it's
already getting dark that's what we deal
with all winter long when we're pushing
snow
make sure you have your light situation
figured out your tractor has flashes for
a reason now
is a great time to use them if you're
going out into a public road
even inside your neighborhood in the
cul-de-sac for instance i know i like to
put my flashers on make sure i have all
my lights on every single one
i want to be seen from every different
angle you might think you're just going
out there really quick to turn around
and spin back and come back up the
driveway
that's when accidents happen
now's a really good time to check out
your lights turn them on
give a look around see if anything needs
to be replaced oh
well looks like i have work to do and if
these lights look a little bit brighter
to you
i replaced all six of the work lights
and headlights with an led bulb
for less than 80 bucks switching out
those halogens to these leds has been
one of the first things i've done on
every tractor i've owned
it's super easy to do i really love the
clarity of these lights and it just
allows me to see so much better when i'm
working at night
now of course the worst or possibly the
best mistake that you can make is the
dreaded you buy a new piece of snow
removal equipment
and it doesn't snow curse but that's
okay we don't buy this kind of snow
removal product just for one season it's
meant to last us for years and years to
come so if we can pay to keep the snow
away for just one year
i know most of us won't be complaining
well hopefully you found that fun and
informative and will help you avoid
making those mistakes this winter
if you wouldn't mind consider giving me
a thumbs up a thumbs down and subscribe
to my channel by clicking that button
below
and don't forget if you're interested in
something you saw in this video read
through that description right down
below as well you'll see all sorts of
helpful links down there for tractor
owners
well until next time stay safe we'll see
you soon
you